[Applaus]
dieser film erzählt die geschichte von
samui friedman
er hat sich mit elf jahren die
schläfenlocken abgeschnitten und sich
entschieden auszusteigen
auszusteigen aus dem streng orthodoxen
judentum in das er hineingeboren wurde
[Musik]
sein weg ist ungewiss und bisweilen
einsam und doch führt er ihn in die
tiefen sehnsüchte seiner seele
ich verachte für verstorbene dass all
das was an rundungen interessiert
interessiert mich null ich habe damals
gewusst dass mich der fußball
interessiert wieder liebgott
sorry ist also und rasch neu ist dass
das irgendwann mal wahrscheinlicher so
eskalieren wird dass ich dann emmental
fordere von der religion wird sie oder
vor dem 1
[Musik]
samuel friedman ist 39 jahre alt er
arbeitet als geschäftsführer in einem
restaurant
vieles was für die meisten menschen
selbstverständlich ist musste er sich
erkämpfen es hat mich schon sehr lang
her definiert
das ist schon sehr lang
alles hätte damit erklären so ok ich
weiß es nicht will ich jetzt so
vermieden oder ich kann dass er so nett
kollegin von meiner freundin hat mich
mal bezeichnet als der begonnen auch
unter der jude so hat fünf minuten mit
mir reden nichts wisse dass ein ausstieg
sie
benötige bin ja
[Musik]
sein leben ist eng mit zürich verbunden
seine herzens statt der stadt seines
liebsten fußball clubs der stadt in der
er auf widerstände stößt und trotz allem
auch nestwärme erfährt
[Musik]
friedman scheut den schmerz nicht es
gebe momente im leben da müsste man ihn
zu lassen so zum beispiel auf dem
schragen der tätowiererin sarah fleur
sie sticht in einer samurai maske
sein 17 tastatur
bayern münchen mit mir san mir und zu
ja das hat das anderes andere benötigt
dann aber das geburtsdatum familie
tochter mit ihrem namen da das was mich
bewegt im lager das ist der glaube
erfolg also an straftäter sondern immer
am eigenen volk glaube
ja also habe ich jedes tattoo andere
andere bewegen andere
andere grund und bauphase sind einfach
ein
tastatur will service
im judentum sind die akkus nicht erlaubt
wie es die meine jüdische friedhof
begraben weil du tot bist
und
ja ich mache es nicht anders aus aber
was die andere lied empfindet dass sich
das problem dass ferrari das kann ich
nicht sterben aber zentral vom motto ist
aber gerade den eigenen weg und das ist
mein weg und ein wertvoller tattoos und
weil es der pastor soll
sollten sich mit mir im berg der kreuze
und dann ist dann ist ja alles gut
[Musik]
samuel stammt aus einer streng orthodox
jüdischen familie die tätowiererin aus
einer syrisch orthodoxen die religion
ist ein thema wohin er auch geht
ja sie sind dort war spitz ich halt auch
sehr sehr religiös und sehr sehr
verschlossen oder gar inneres clubs
nicht zu extrem sie so wird's gemacht
worden dass sie jetzt doch irgendwann
nochmaligen wir durch seinen kaffee
trinken oder normale kraft zu tanken
[Musik]
er ist mit der liebe hoffen
ich wusste ja egal ob gott glaubt
[Musik]
mit
so
geboren in israel kommt samuel friedman
mit neun jahren nach zürich die eltern
arbeiten in der gastronomie
sie erziehen ihre fünf kinder mit viel
liebe und noch mehr regeln wir haben
ferien verbracht im wohl locker
kempen
kempe
anders die jüdische gemeinde und das hat
es nicht auf dem züricher jetzt sind wir
die einzige bucerius und
das duschen und stein am rhein ein
großer friesen gebaut wo wir das größere
fleiß und können mit transportiere ich
wäre ja und dann haben wir die erfahrung
dass ungefähr gefilmt und sind dann
umkreis in europa
[Musik]
ich fasse costa rica ist so die die
duschen helfen campingplatz und und
aufbau und abbau und kragen der tat des
schlamm und
auf ihren reisen erhalten die kinder
einblick in eine welt die ihnen im
alltag in zürich verborgen bleibt
die friedmans gehören zur
ultra-orthodoxen jüdischen gemeinde akku
dass achim und leben streng nach den 613
ge und verboten der thora
[Musik]
zum beispiel darf den kindern erst mit
drei jahren die haare geschnitten werden
[Musik]
seine kindheit sei behütet und voller
liebe gewesen
und doch spürt er schon früh dass ihn
das leben außerhalb des frommen rahmens
zwischen synagoge schule und familie
anzieht
du brauchst dich in religion hof und
glauben das wichtigste ist wo es geht
das geht nicht wichtig ist wie die ganze
im juni
die rede ganz wie viel das ist völlig
banal eigentlich das ist
wie ein fernseher das ist
nicht normal wie sie der idee des
kreises sie damals die hand auch nicht
drüber der friede also mir hat ein
fernsehkabel magistratischen im schrank
verschwunden und
alles reden volk sich dann
warum oder warum haben rheine war minute
traf eine habe du kritisierst an das
hatte grauzone und
du fragst dich dann okay wie
grauzone was kann ich noch machen
und darüber erzählen oder was ist
eigentlich da wo sie in den lichtern
grenze
mit elf jahren trifft samuel eine
entscheidung fürs leben er schneidet
sich die schläfenlocken ab sein erster
akt der rebellion sie symbolisiert
gebracht viel oder du bist
brandete schwer am markt und das sei
nicht immer wieder ja
der tag der mein leben veränderte
und wie ist reaktion von ihnen morgens
müssen
[Musik]
man musste
zurückholen
und orthodoxer sie haben sie sind dann
seid ihr fremde wurde also sie sind dann
schweizer wurde
und da hab ich für sie
das abspielen der schläfe locker ist
nicht okay sie aber
sie haben sagen irgendwann
wahrscheinlich verstanden werden sie
kennt auch die andere die andere die
normale religiöse wald und der hat halt
nicht alles schläft locker so
dass sie dies
um die lange schleife loch ha
[Musik]
die richtige fallen natürlich hat mich
angesprochen aber jeder student
realisiert oder auf annualisierte dass
es mir egal ist was andere über mich
denken
in der schweiz gibt es insgesamt 18.000
juden ein kleiner aber auffälliger teil
davon knapp 3000 gehört zu der
ultra-orthodoxen jüdischen gemeinschaft
in zürich wiedikon es ist eine
konservative gar geschlossene
gemeinschaft die sich abgrenzen willen
die männer in schwarzen anzügen und hut
die frauen mit rock und perücke
[Musik]
der jüdische journalist yves kugelmann
kennt die immensen widerstände die ein
aussteiger wie samuel friedman
überwinden muss wenn er die gemeinschaft
verlässt und orthodoxe gemeinschaft sind
dort tolle gemeinschaft im sinn vor so
bestimmt es robin art trifft massiv ins
persönliche habe vom individuum vans
individuum überhaupt service seit wenn
der persönliche glaube dass mir wird
weekend and
individualisiert wird weitgehend fremd
bestimmt aber für vieles gar nicht so
eine
art wechsel video shows auf vox also die
ältere in den familien habe ja schon so
und die war da schon vor dem abi
nachnominiert in ihrem alltag das heißt
für uns nimmt und aus dem meer war oder
bei denen in dem prozess vor der
ablösung alles
hinterfragen und versuchte mal dass in
einklang zu bringen mit der umwelt und
dem urlaub
hier im zürcher kreis 3 hat sagen
wilfried man den größten teil seiner
kindheit verbrachte seine kindheit
geprägt von regeln und normen die männer
beten zwei bis dreimal täglich in der
synagoge die kinder besuchen eine nach
geschlecht getrennt die jüdische schule
ich habe da immer neue schulen aber die
sind jetzt gegen ende womit sie sind
schwester aus das ist der holt sie
fertig mit
netz viel wie klingt so
wirtschaftspolitik sind alle
dem umkreis von 300 metern
auspuff der nation nannte man damals in
den 90ern die zürcher weststraße
der schwerverkehr wälzte sich zweispurig
durch die quartierstrasse eine
rußschicht überzogen die häuser viele
jüdische familien wohnen immer noch hier
in gehdistanz zu ihrer synagoge ist ein
verkappter alter
im ersten stock also im hochbau denn ich
sehe euch so ist schuld sondern fünf
zimmer wohnung und sagte wir wollen
dieses clusters sie ja die straße sei in
einem zimmer also wir haben
hauptsächlich jüdische fachunterricht
gab torwart almut all dieser halt wenn
er die fehler aber am tag sowie zum 3
und dann vom trubel sinnvoll wir diese
sache sehen oder richtung
smart die
englisch französisch
solche profanen damit sie doch spitze
unterstützt vom staat bekommen also gar
keine wahl
dies ist im
programm 7 ist eine synagoge am
samstag taxi so behütet
ja
ich bin mit 14 eigentlich weg von züri
des internets
eine familie rabbinerin in der schule
läuft seit es ist alles verboten was
bringt dir sagt dass erlaubt ist und das
ist atmen und im internet hannich spiel
mitgespielt hätte einen maturaabschluss
und werkstätten überholt haben ihr
studium abgeschlossen und an sachlicher
als ob
und nachher wird dann komplett
gewechselt und
klassik
[Musik]
das ist noch nie
die erste permanente
berührung mit dem
freilos hat man die brembo
nichtreligiöse ist frei
ja
die gewonnene freiheit schmeckt ihm sie
riecht aber auch nach alkohol drogen und
pokerspiel im rausch versuchte
herauszufinden wer er ist und nimmt
einige irrfahrten auf sich dinge auf die
er jahrelang verzichtet hat lebt er nun
exzessiv aus wie das rauchen am schabbat
ja sowieso aufträgen sowie es
laut kammerer hat in religiöse kamin hat
schlussendlich du verlasse wald wo du
kannst ihn richtig vor der wahl wo du es
aber nicht richtig an
du weißt was dich genau erwartet und du
weißt nicht ob die familie mitmacht
man tigers und satellit
ich glaube immer das was sie gelabert ob
sie da nicht sagen juli steht und für
die glücks- und
dann fragst dich was wirklich dort sehr
und ja es gibt das gibt es eine szene im
wolkenbruch wohnen im hotel
modul drillisch nachdem er kapiert hat
dass das er eigentlich nie verloren hat
so vor links und vor acht
dieser konnte
[Musik]
mehrere
und die szene gott apoll minute und
stevan r
vielleicht einen guten ratschlag
aus dem einstigen vorbeter samuel
friedman wird ein nicht religiöser
mensch der völlig anders lebt als er
erzogen wurde
das unterschiedliche tage sehr
gemeinschaftlich
einer sitzt in der familie aber vor
allem auch miteinander um staatlich eins
bis zwei mal in die synagoge zum gebet
mit 70 million zusammen viele vor den
tag und vor der periode neben johanna
gemeinschaftlicher anteil der vierten
oder radikal also sozusagen sind schon
gar nicht dass ich gemeinschaft dass sie
nicht einmal ganz unbedingt freunde wie
mir das zu verstehen wo muss ich dafür
die entscheiden sonst wirklich
gemeinschaft im urlaub der alltag
zusammen das thema kann sich die
menschen unter vertrag also der tour
über nacht zur tage
abkapselt wird vor allem vor allem muss
ein vertrauen
verliert und
nicht fremd sehe ich also mit dolly
fremde entlohnt wird das ist trauma
natürlich
erstaunt aber das massive existenzielle
prüfungen das kann sich jeder vorstellen
und beschreiben zugeordneten auf die
jüdische thematik das nach massiv hier
ereignet und je nachdem wie stark
persönlichkeit ist das noch mal ganz
anders zu ordern
samuel friedman arbeitet heute als
geschäftsführer in einem japanischen
restaurant
nach seiner zeit im internat in israel
heiratet er eine jüdin sie bekommen eine
tochter doch die ehe hält nicht lange
sie haben das gemeinsame sorgerecht
das verhältnis zu ex frau sei aber
schwierig die tochter und er hingegen
seien sich sehr nah zweimal pro woche
übernachtete sie bei ihm in diesem film
auftreten will sie lieber nicht
essen ein sehr flexibler und offener
chef man kann mit allen zu ihm kommen
mit alle über alles mit ihm reden das
finde ich super und zuerst da oftmals 1
aber dann schlussendlich geht es dann
schon und von dem er ich schätze das
sehr
er schreibt manchmal führung
das mag ich zum beispiel auch so ich bin
eher als vor einigen stress dass ich
werde er ich bin ja nicht mehr so nicht
ruhig deshalb ist er ein mensch der wird
ein dieselauto
ja die diagnose und
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der ablösungsprozess ging schrittweise
vonstatten obwohl er schon als kind
anzuecken begann hat er erst vor sechs
jahren das letzte äußerliche symbol der
zugehörigkeit zur jüdischen religion die
kippa auf dem kopf abgelegt
anfangs habe er sich nackt gefühlt
[Musik]
der eingeschlagene weg wurde zur
zerreißprobe für die ganze familie vor
allem seinen eltern habe er sehr viel
zugemutet
[Musik]
sikora friedman arbeitet als köchin in
einer jüdischen schule
einmal pro woche ist samuel bei seinen
eltern zu hause
[Musik]
schauen zum teil sehr vieles ist klassik
wichtige bin sehr sehr dick sie als kind
dann ich mache wieder abgenommen noch
wieder mega zurück das begleitet mich
das ganze aber man muss die jetzt immer
als satz ich mag meine eltern so brauche
montag aus oberbach
eine süßigkeit der schublade das hatten
sie sich
wirklich
hasste ich immer im raum die großmutter
von birinyi klopp verwischt hat sich die
geister der ist die frage wie geht's dir
dass du folgst aus kassel hunkel sie zu
aber dies ist wirklich zusätzlich achten
muss dass ich dir die generation wo
holocaust-überlebende das ist immer
auftritts sie die hand nie zum massaker
und bier ist zurzeit
das ist
irre war in israel zum lehrer nehmen
und einen tag ich bekomme von ihm ein
telefon man darf ich meine kippa kaufen
weil wir haben stufe auch mit kuba
bis dann ihre ist gegangen so schwartze
samt keeper
und er wollte er hat gesagt das spricht
nicht mit das bin ich nicht
hab ich gesagt du bist genug gewachsen
du darfst tauschen was du willst und
danach riss gekommen nachbar monat noch
ein telefon und dann waren noch niedrige
stufe
aber dann habe ich gedacht ist das ist
die letzte stufe weil er es zurück nach
schweiz gekommen die männer mit kippa
immer mit uns schabbat gemacht die mehr
koscher die gäste nie mehr also zu hause
waren wie die monroe man dann für mich
war religiös
in den hintergrund er war nicht mehr das
habe ich erfahren ganz ganz langsam er
war verheiratet mit der tochter
das war
zwar lang aber
er ist mein sohn
ich habe nicht mehr so gemeinsam mit
gott er muss die machen seine rechnung
nicht mit mir er weist er ich bin für
ihm für alles
sind sie trotzdem stolz sie
ihre miete für das jede dame
ja dass er
zurückkommt nach hause ich sagen soll er
eine jüdische frau kennenlernen lieben
die unterirdische familie gründen beide
jede dafür dass
mit
tracht
wir haben
wenig bis gar nicht miteinander
kommuniziert hat und
wann das ist relativ
das stetig sie
diskutieren über sache oder erfindet so
muss es machen und ich finde
ich nicht dazu zwingen
ihr glück mit dem dass sie mich
akzeptiert haben wir andere an passierte
was exakt jährigen nicht zur änderung
viel feeling ich
weiß nicht ob er von diesen würden sehr
viele na ja
wir haben schon gesagt er ist mein sohn
ich liebe
und der ich eine fontäne und ich habe
gleich gleich einige mehr klug
klassisch jüdischer
bücher schreibt
die volkacher moses in verschiedenen
varianten
du hast sie so immer
schwieriger da sind alle gleich alle
drei verschiedene
erklärungen oft
erfolglosen dann ruft zu fünf bücher
moses hat dann die
chance da nämlich stark das sind jedoch
die sind erklärung für träger von du
hast bei fünf bücher moses und auf
deiner art der talmud das sind dann die
augen blau wanderte das ist das
eigentlich total modisch sozusagen
jüdische gesetz braucht es wird jedes
teil im lager jeder abschnitt im alltag
die situation noch passieren wird
dadurch nur und ich eigentlich so lieb
hat analysiert was ich war vor
familie reserviert und scheider bis zu
kaltes lehne oder wenn du in der
business lounge an kollegen und geht
kaputt wer ist schuld und sowie die uns
wirklich sehr wie die situation im lager
wird dann unser land kommen dann wieder
neue ideen von zauber
anstand ist es mega auf teils oder du
hast dann durch der hauptteil den hass
der eint die antiklerikalen die andere
klinik zu 40 jähriger musste sie unter
sich das zuschauen es ist so kalt dass
alles lernen in der jugend zu ab 54 lars
lernen bis 45 c lernst folgen für moses
und mich nach und nach davon stammen zum
teil mut und mit der mechanischen fertig
also
immer immer wieder immer wieder weil es
zum beispiel wenn kommt und ich habe
etwas frage habe eine buch zum gucken
was darf ich machen diese und die
situation und dann ist klar und geht gut
ja klare regel viel rede und wir halten
das ja
wir geben unsere beste
[Musik]
ich musste vorher und dann sauber team
summe ressort fertigung zahlen idries
comeback du bist ein ganz starkes
kollektiv fernsehen lesen das buch dann
dieses buch
ist
gespielt
beschäftigt man
buchen die sachen sicher
ist aber schon mal
zeichnete verschrieben
alles wird mich sehr denn
wirklich gott hat gesagt sie nun die
klage sehe ich das unglück ist
durchschnitt erschafft für am sabbat
dorfschmied neues kreieren warum du
darfst theoretisch steinbauer lego ist
eine besonders gute figur
auf dich traust du dir mut machen
es geht seine gegner sondern gesplittet
wenn ich will mit dir wetter das was
eine zusage dass lego roboter das habe
ich noch nicht verstehe so
aber bescheiden wir das sehr viel am
sabbat aufseher freenet machen das ist
so dass der dorfmeister verbot hat
schwimmen
wie viel licht wird trinke dann wird das
holz netz um die kette vom ertrinken und
dann erschaffst du durch dass das boot
und dass der abstand zu dem transporter
[Musik]
oder
wie seine eltern wohnt auch samuel in
zürich wiedikon
zusammen mit seiner freundin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das ist ein fehler von
cilic meckel los posierte kollegen das
muss ich wecken was er noch drauf
gedrückt
das moped
samuel ist erfolgreich im job
in der liebe hat er schon ein paar
anläufe genommen dieses mal hofft er
inständig dass es hält seit eineinhalb
jahren ist er mit bin ja zusammen
dass seine freundin nicht jüdin ist
scheint keinen von beiden zu stören
das ding ja hingegen alleine wohnen
möchte und deswegen wieder aus zieht aus
der gemeinsamen wohnung das fällt schwer
zu akzeptieren
[Musik]
und ich bin
betroffen
ist und ablage p oder sache bevor sie
vor sie weltweit
[Musik]
mit dem zusammen wohnen wir nicht
zusammen war eine komische an wo sich
geklettert warum sie sich das mache es
ist okay was muss jetzt ihren weg geht
dass ich meine ich bitte letzt wurde
dann
irgendwo sein eigener weg fort und und
sogar dass das geht ja darum dass sie
musste schrittmacher für wohnen und
da bin ich der letzte sein
das mache er mit und ich wollte nicht
und du musst da bliebe es sowieso
niemanden zu seinem glück zwingen
vernünftig das ist ein teil von neues m
ja und wir so akzeptieren wie sie sind
und so vernünftig wie möglich sie als
geschiedene mann weiß dass was geht und
was nicht die kraft gut und du lernst
die kralle spätestens dann
[Gelächter]
die ultra orthodoxe gemeinde in zürich
wiedikon ist klein man kennt sich
wenn samuel hier unterwegs ist ruft
seine anwesenheit ein breites spektrum
an gefühlsregungen hervor
haben
[Applaus]
meinen
einige gamer immer im
[Musik]
kopf
haben
liga schaffte und du ich glaube houska
fokus
der autoshow
okay
ich hatte richtig
sagt er ich weiß nicht ich glaube es ist
auto ist glaube ich benutze ich
vielleicht wird aus ähnlich sehen die
alle über die linie kam toyota previa
bauen sie besitzt
anfragen für dreh bewilligungen wurden
alle abgelehnt
es dauert auch hier nicht lange da wird
das kamerateam draußen um samuel
friedman entdeckt
aber
sobald das gebäude filmen stehen dadurch
sofort das interessiert sofort was
passiert
das ist so typisch aber es gibt immerhin
ein paar wohl irgendwie doch wenigstens
gemäß 30
kopf und malz noch nicht verloren
also ja für mich krass problem ich meine
ich bin mehr sozial und ich gehe sie
aber
sie sind nicht so fern von mir die angst
vieler
quasi beruf gemacht
vor mir geschlagen jemand durch
gestiegen nach mir schon jemand lang
jemand ausgestiegen aber sich so quasi
es ist das was ich nicht gern zehnt dass
das ausgestiegen ist hanna folge es geht
ihm gut er hat nur kontakt zu seiner
familie
und ist nur so flach und gab das kohle
gerade unterliegen also weiß dass ich
wollte halt unbedingt das ist nicht so
aber
ich fühle mich jetzt frei kriegen wir
wegziehen und frauen bahnen soll ich auf
israel sagte das den druck und wird
genau wie ich sie konnte die familie
wohl drohte sich nehmen andere land
siegen wir neues labor von manch eine
tochter
das würde ich die raue natur also vor
dem herrn
elisabeth man
schätzt nachricht
der center
in der region wo sie gemeint und musik
wir sagen dass die aufnahme
koblach kannst du jeden fall
spannend wäre hätte deine nachricht alle
womit mir oft recht
früh verstanden dass all das was ein
rundum interessiert interessiert mich
null nicht die ganze religionsgeschichte
ganze glaube und gold und
heilig sie und gott und und nur hockey
die synagoge und die ganze angelegenheit
haben ja schon mit mitzuhelfen eine
gewisse das ist nicht das was ich will
ich habe damals gewusst dass mich der
fußball mehr interessiert wieder
liebgott
sorry ist also
der fußball ist friedmans
religionsersatz als das engmaschige netz
der ultra orthodoxe jüdische
gemeinschaft reißt lässt er sich vom
fußball auffangen und treiben
als vermummter der südkurve war auch er
einer der paten zündete und sich gar
gefechte mit der polizei lieferte
vor ein paar jahren hat er aufgehört
sich zu vermummen
vollblut fern ist er noch immer
sie soll
[Musik]
immer für dich da
zuverlässige meint
gemeinschaft
community und du wirst oft fange durch
andere gemeinschaft wo haltegurt wird im
himmel ist und ein stifter rosa und
heißt halt maradona
ja das ist so
so sei einerseits
soll letztlich
darum ist hier
[Musik]
es macht den anschein als sei samuel
schon ein paar mal vor einem drohenden
abgrund umgekehrt als hätte er die kurve
im letzten moment noch gekriegt
verluste nimmt er in kauf für ihn gilt
alles oder nichts er wirkt hart und
abgeklärt und doch trägt er seine
familie und freunde fest im herzen
[Musik]
so auch an diesem morgen
samuel ist seit dem morgengrauen auf den
beinen bereits vor der arbeit hat er
etwas gemacht von dem er wohl selber
dachte dass er das nie mehr tun würde er
hat gebetet
foto die kollegin ist gestorben und dann
sitzt man sieben tage lang sie besitzt
die
hsg stil und trugen
und
da ich werde morgen das morgengebet und
sie wohnen den christnacht hatte die
stadt um darum
halte das für sie mobil wachstum in
samana sie und da hat sie mich folgt das
intro
unterstützen und dann macht man modernes
ritual ist dass man einander das sind so
sabrina legt und die haben dann auch
etwas tradition
und haben sie
wird unterstützt und hat dadurch für
formate nach
20 jahren ist mal wieder die welt
erfahren fans nicht
so lustig mit der tattoos gebet rivale
ge ist doch schizophren dass
mir bedeutet mit
ihrer hilfe geschehen ich meine idee
sich als religiös aber nur nachteile man
versteht glaubt man traditionell sehr
schlimm aus wie sushi mal da und ich
glaube das ist wichtig und so
warum er ja und ich kann halt für das
problem
etwas verzerrt und sie hatten mehr
gefreut erzählt sie
stolz
jüdisch zu sein scheint mehr zu bedeuten
als an gott zu glauben und gebote zu
achten
samuel friedman der aussteiger der mann
der vermeintlich gebrochen hat mit
seiner religion trägt in seinem tiefsten
inneren eine jüdische identität
eine jüdische identität auf die er sehr
stolz ist
einmal pro woche trainiert er die
g-junioren des jüdischen fußballvereins
fc hk
die schrift kapsel am türrahmen zu
küssen hat er verinnerlicht
bisweilen ist eher irritiert über seine
gewohnheiten die er auch nach jahren
nicht abzulegen vermag
was
hast du hast es ja nur in husum mit mit
jüdischem diese collection ob du weißt
dass ganz genau was befindet sich das du
musst deine meinung
unter den eltern der kinder die er
trainiert sind auch ultra orthodoxe
jüdische dabei bisher hätten alle sehr
gut auf ihn reagiert
[Musik]
aber
viele
[Musik]
[Applaus]
reihe durch je nach meliá bitte
also mit
den job mit den nah dran ist gut mit den
durch wärme langsam und laufen
[Applaus]
gemalt und
ausdruck dagegen
ist
also freistoß wie real alle user wieder
spiele ich wieder spiele
stolz auf mini herkunft besteht auf dem
volk ihr seid jetzt nicht mit dem
judentum als religion steward
[Musik]
münster ist so
lustig finde
dich von deinem befrieden und
die stunde von butt hervor
vermutlich
beträge von der iran geht ja vor dem
problem alles was nicht erlaubt und auch
sehr schöne
familiäre ist sehr sehr schön familie
habe ich super
traditionen sind an und für sich ja
schlecht ist auch tradition soll ja
niemand melodie erklärt er selbst ganz
schön man nicht
irgendwo habe ich mich immer noch nicht
wo ihr melodie quer dass ich mit singen
so dass ich mir den kopf halten
und mit sinn finde das
ein schöner teil von der community und
etwas erzwungen eine das dumpfe stroms
und die andere sache wo sollte er sehr
schön sind und ja
weiß nicht warum man jetzt ein tram h
ohne unsere das gab einen machen
[Musik]
so gerne samuel über die abzweigungen in
seinem leben selber entscheidet so
schmerzhaft kann es sein wenn jemand
anderes diesen part übernimmt
samuels freundin hat sich von ihm
getrennt
das passiert
ja es ist bisher nicht ganz so sehr
sehr hart dran ist für mich ein wenig
schneller so erwartet haben
selbige leichter
fällt man halt
dich wartet oder halt für die stars
ja
ja das feld
[Musik]
der nördlichste kam von den weniger in
das sportheim
[Musik]
ist der weg ausgestiegen
ist so einsam wie du dir gestoppt ist
ich halte spa für sich haben in der
gastro schäfer und dadurch sehr schnell
sehr viel soziale kontakte knüpfen und
ich bin gespannt
wie sie büßten im einsatz sie uns aber
das ist jedenfalls gab es irgendwo aber
ich glaube dadurch dass ich aus höheren
sozialen bin oder von mir behaupten die
consozial bin
da nicht nach schnell neu gute soziale
kontakte
[Musik]
hier seien ihr auskommen
samuel friedmans leben für die freiheit
ein ablösungsprozess von gott eine suche
nach sich selbst
[Musik]